- Your sex life is bad.
No way.
- I'm Kevin.
- I'm Mallory.
And we're gonna take--
- 15 of the hardest relationship questions
that really make you think.
- Quiz, number one.
You and your partner have been together
for a couple of years when
they forget your birthday.
You wait all day for
them to acknowledge it
but by the next morning, they
still haven't said a word.
Would you end the relationship?
If I forgot your birthday,
would you end the relationship?
- Nah.
- Yeah, I wouldn't either.
- I would never forget yours.
I feel like you're so busy
you would forget mine.
- I would never forget yours.
Your birthday's, 12, 12.
You literally can't forget 12, 12.
When's my birthday?
Shoot it, shoot it, go.
- August 26th.
- 27th, just kidding it's 26.
(laughs)
- You and your partner haven't really
been having much sex recently.
- That sounds right. (laughs)
- When you sit down to talk about it,
they say that they want to experiment,
and ask if you'd be happy
to open the relationship
for a trial period.
Would you end the relationship?
- Yes.
- You just said it 'cause of me.
But would you?
- Yeah.
- But what if I said
open relationship with another female?
- I would hope maybe
it was another female.
- You would hope it was another female?
Sweating, okay.
On your wedding day, you find out
that your partner had an affair.
Oh, chop the nuts off.
When you confront them about
it, they swear that it's over
and you believe them.
Never!
The wedding is all paid for
and your guests have started to arrive.
Would you end the rela--
Yes, end it!
Would you?
- Yeah.
- You're scared now.
- The wedding's already paid for?
- Yeah.
- You've been with your
partner for a little while
when you find out they cheated
in their last relationship.
It wasn't that they were unhappy
or that there were problems
in the relationship,
they just slipped up.
Would you end the relationship?
- You cheat on me, what happens?
- You cut my dick off?
- That's correct.
Let's remember this, it's on camera now.
No one cheats on anyone.
No, I would not end the relationship.
80% said no.
The past is the past.
- They're understanding, yeah.
- Number five, you find
out from somebody else
that your partner has
kissed another person.
You thought you were both
happy and there seems to be
no reason for it.
Would you end the relationship?
- This could happen to you.
Like someone would strike first at you,
you wouldn't do it but someone would--
- Someone would strike at me?
- Yeah, I think they would make a move.
- Would you dump me?
- No.
- Really?
But I'd be in major trouble.
You find out your partner has
been messaging somebody else.
The messages are flirty
and you're not happy
with them at all, but
as far as you're aware,
your partner hasn't met up with
the person they're texting.
Would you end the relationship?
- I mean I would never do it
but I'm just saying--
- You wouldn't break up with me?
- I wouldn't break up with you.
- If I was like, hey babe, hey like,
I don't even know what is like flirty.
- I always think about the other person
'cause I feel like they
would misinterpret.
If it seemed intentional then maybe but.
- Yeah, I would break up.
Whoa.
It's like 50, 50, 53 yes and 47 no.
- Your partner is very flirty,
almost inappropriately so.
You know it's their personality,
and have no reason to think
they're cheating on you,
but their flirting makes
you feel uncomfortable.
- Okay, alright, okay.
- Would you end the relationship?
- Alright.
- No,
'cause I've seen it too many times.
- I am not that flirty.
I'm flirty with a lot of
women but not a lot of men.
Your sex life is bad.
No way.
Not just mediocre, it's terrible.
You just don't seem
compatible in bed at all,
no matter how many times you've tried.
Would you end the relationship.
- Yeah.
I mean how do you even get to
that point where you're like.
- No you use like porn and stuff, right?
You give it a chance.
- I feel like if it's not amazing
the first 10 times then.
- 10 times?
- I'd give them yeah, a big
enough sample to figure it out.
(laughs)
- Okay, you're nice.
- After dating for a couple of weeks,
you make plans for your partner
to meet your best friend.
Afterwards, your friend
pulls you to one side
and explains that they don't
like your partner at all.
Would you end the relationship?
With the friend or with the--
(laughs)
No, yeah I feel like I'm too nice
I would probably give the
person so many chances.
- Yeah me too.
- Even if they,
if they were that bad.
- Yeah, well we don't have a back bone.
- Yeah.
- Oh no.
85%, humanity doesn't have a back bone.
Your partner always makes
fun of you in front of people
in an attempt to make
everybody else laugh.
You don't really think
much of it to begin with,
but it soon becomes a regular occurrence.
Would you end the relationship?
- No.
- No?
- 'Cause I think we enjoy doing
it to each other sometimes.
- Well, it's always makes fun of you.
- Always makes fun of you.
- I make fun of you pretty often
but because I love you.
- But it's not like, we
don't really mean it.
There's like a tinge of truth in it but.
- There's truth in it.
It's not a tinge.
This is the last one.
You and your partner have been watching
a Netflix series together.
You find out that they watched
the season finale without you.
Would you end the relationship?
The only thing we watch
religiously is Westworld.
- Yeah, that's coming up.
- And I would never
watch that without you.
- Okay, that would be the test.
- So, the question is,
would you break up, no.
- No.
Okay, thank God.
I thought that said yes, 92% no.
So we just finished the quiz,
which was awesome and we got
to know a lot about each other.
What should they do next?
- Click the link in the quiz, or.
(laughs)
Click the link in the description.
- Down below, thanks for watching!
(guitar music)